it's one thing to say that gender is
performed and that's a little different
from saying gender is performative when
we say gender is performed we usually
mean that we've taken on a role we're
acting in some way and that our acting
or a role playing is crucial to the
gender that we are and the gender that
we present to the world to say that
gender is performative is a little
different because for something to be
performative means that it produces a
series of effects we act and walk and
speak and talk in ways that consolidate
an impression of being a man or being a
woman I was walking down the street in
Berkeley when I first arrived several
years ago and a young woman who is I
think in high school
leaned out of her window and she yelled
are you a lesbian and she was looking to
harass me or maybe she was just freaked
out or she thought I looked like I
probably was one and wanted to know but
instead I just turned around and I said
yes I am
and that really shocked her we act as if
that being of a man or that being of a
woman is actually an internal reality or
something that's simply true about us a
fact about us actually it's a phenomenon
that's being produced all the time and
reproduced all the time so to say gender
is performative is to say that nobody
really is a gender from the start
I know it's controversial but that's my
claim
think about how difficult it is for
sissy boys or how difficult it is for
tomboys to function socially without
being bullied or without being teased or
without sometimes suffering threats of
violence or without their parents
intervening to say maybe you need a
psychiatrist or why can't you be normal
so you know there are institutional
powers like psychiatric normalization
and there are informal kinds of
practices like bullying which try to
keep us in our gendered place there's a
real question for me about how such
gender norms get established and policed
and what the best way is to disrupt them
and to overcome the police function it's
my view that gender is a is culturally
formed but it's also a domain of agency
or freedom it's most important to resist
the violence that is imposed by ideal
gender norms especially against those
who are gender different who are
non-conforming in their in their gender
presentation